e
all right good
morning
we have uh four bills to discuss this
morning we have amendments to all of
them so the committee members have
those um I'd like to start with 8B
11:31 that's okay with the
subcommittee
did you want to what did you want to
introduce this one it's you worked on it
so yes I was filling in
on the subcommittee on this one and what
the amendment does is instead of adding
a
specific organization to the list of
ones that don't need that ones that can
have
unlicensed
practitioners or conditional
practitioners for that
matter and simply
described the type of organization that
that app that qualifies so it's a
organization that provides clinical
Mental Health Services employs licensed
practitioners provides clinical
supervision and assumes
responsibility so we don't care if it's
for profit or not for profit that's
that's really irrelevant to the type of
organization that to the type of
business but if they've got a structure
of mental health
um services including some licensed
practitioners who can be the supervisors
then they're allowed to hire
um new graduates unlicensed people or
people with
um conditional
licenses and and supervise them and it's
the it gives them the umbrella of the
organization to the work of the
supervis and I think I thought the
subcommittee thought that was the
simplest way to address the
issue guys any
comments yeah I I would agree that I
think it's the easiest way to handle the
situation and I think from my personal
perspective I think it just does what
the statute arguably already did um but
there was some confusion around it I
think the language is much more clear
and uh will hopefully help to solve any
any confusion yeah the
apparently a for-profit clinic was being
treated differently than a non
for-profit Clinic while doing the same
type of work and nobody thought that was
an appropriate situation
y um so if there's no further discussion
from the subcommittee I would entertain
a motion if anybody has one on
amendments
1071 not all move to
adopts thanks
BR all right so the motion is ought to
pass on Amendment
1071 uh all in favor just hands is fine
R okay so um we'll recommend to the full
committee the adoption and then um I
will also move a to pass with Amendment
um any discussion on that or sorry
second first do I have a second thanks
Steve
um all right no discussion all in favor
of odd to pass with Amendment 4 Z
perfect
all right that's 11:31 let's move to
1413 um so this was a bill that came to
us because there was some concern um
that um mental health licensed mental
health professionals uh when they assume
responsibility for um somebody would be
legally responsible for them outside of
the purview of their professional um
kind of responsibilities uh when they're
when they're giving Mental Health
Services um and that didn't make any
sense so I just wanted to clarify it uh
we used language here um that is also in
um actually the bill that we just did um
which is RSA
33834 and we just changed it to the
supervisor shall assume professional
ethical and legal responsibility for
mental health services provided by the
candidate and a written agreement on
record with the board so we added uh
ethical and legal responsibility for
mental health services provided just to
make sure that you know they were only
going to be held accountable um when
they're doing their job and also I I
wanted to keep the legal component in
there because I do think that there
should be some oversight and
accountability I don't think that they
should be without that um so that's
basically what this amendment does any
comments from the
subcommittee
yes one comment is that we did get
testimony that the other Lang in that
section describing what a supervisory
agreement was was supported by the by
the
practitioners and this leaves that
language in there which I think is
better than just a leading at wholesale
to get de deal with the clarification
yes this will replace the whole bill so
uh originally this was going to delete
an entire section um of RSA and instead
of doing that we're just fine-tuning to
what the actual concern was so I think
it simplifies it a lot um so uh if
there's no further discussion I'd
entertain a
motion thanks a to pass so the move is a
to pass on Amendment
1076 do have a second Steve thank you um
any discussion I don't think so all in
favor I
four and then having adopted that well
or recommending that uh ought to pass
with
Amendment I'll move do have a second red
all in favor I perfect we'll make that
recommendation to the full committee 4
Zer all right um third Bill
1079 per approve have you had a chance
to look through it do you have any con
do you have concerns with anything in
there okay come on up and let us
know
good morning uh as we look on page
one uh the line 23 it starts the uh
definition of a critical incident stress
management team and it says you know
manage team of means the group of one or
more trained volunteers including
members of a peer support group
organized by a unit of the State local
County government or members of a union
of Emergency Response Public Safety
workers as defined who offer critical
instance Stress Management intervention
my team is actually started with nashal
fire but then branched out to become a a
nonprofit Standalone
organization yes we have union members
we have all those things in there but we
are not directly connected to to a
union or a city town or state okay I'll
have to go back and look I didn't ask
for a change to that paragraph so I
don't know what happened there um if
something shifted was there something in
there before that isn't there now I just
don't remember off the top of my head uh
I don't think it it connected everything
to
that yes it says including members of PE
support groups it doesn't say only me
all right I just want to make sure okay
yeah cuz I I didn't touch that paragraph
Okay um so for the subcommittee's
benefit what we did is uh in this
amendment if you look on page two um we
created
G um emergency response Public Safety
worker we defined what that was so that
when it's referred to in the rest of the
statute you can go back and know what it
is that we're talking about when we say
that um so it says emergency response
Public Safety worker means any law
enforcement officer certified under RSA
10 6 L certified County corrections
officer sheriff or deputy sheriff state
police officer civilian law enforcement
employee civilian County Corrections
employee any call volunteer or regular
firefighter civilian fire department
employee rescue or ambulance worker
including Ambulance Service emergency
medical personnel first a responder
service and volunteer Personnel Hospital
Emergency Department Personnel
telecommunication uh communicators and
local dispatchers so we added that
section so you can make note of that the
next one on H um we took into
consideration uh representative Smith's
concern uh we changed the language there
from Hospital Emergency Department
Personnel means staff rendering care
rescue support and life saving Services
while working for Andor in the hospital
emergency department he had that concern
that if it was um an employee who was
not actually in the emergency department
at the time that they wouldn't be um
included so uh they can be working for
or they can be working in there at at
the time of the incident or the trauma
and still have access to this um so we
made that adjustment um line
25 um when we're talking about uh the
certification standards um I wanted to
add the commissioner of safety uh to the
icisf or similar organization because I
felt like if we're legislating this and
overseeing this there should be somebody
in the government that's the contact
point for that and the commissioner of
safety seems like the appropriate person
to do that um so the commissioner of
safety can review the training standards
and things of that nature and we do have
some level of accountability there um so
that's another thing that was changed
you can note that if you've got concerns
let me know
um didn't change anything there um so
represent I still do have a concern I I
tried to address it but there didn't
seem to be a good way to do it we didn't
change the language on line four of of
three it page three it's exactly what
you gave to me y um my concern is that
if you want this to um be accessible to
retired persons that isn't spelled out
specifically anywhere and we couldn't
find anywhere to put it in this
particular Amendment but that might be
something that you want to give
consideration to um so I I know that we
mentioned retirees throughout it we do
but I think if you go back and you look
at it the retirees are people who are
providing the services not necessarily
receiving the
services um okay and so just just keep
that in mind um when when it goes over
the I can't do anything about it now I
was talking with the attorney and um she
kept telling me um nor any person so any
person receiving the benefits which is
true but it being a peer support group
and not licensed professionals um they
have to be a peer and the argument I
think could potentially be made that if
you're retired you're no longer up here
it's possible to make that argument and
so if you want um and then you wouldn't
qualify for the services so you wouldn't
be included in there um so I tried to
get that resolved yesterday we ran out
of time um so that's just something you
might want to keep in mind but that's
the language as it came to us and um
that those were the end of the changes
the rest of it is as it came to us um so
any comments Carol um just curious
you're talking about subsections G and H
they're already there are we added G so
G is new
no G right here on line 13 of the amend
I only have the original amend
telecommunicator uh no so it's ch sh
I'll give you the we're proposing
something a little
different I mean I don't object to the
to the what you included but
it I don't understand how it
fit you go thank you need this
any you just added it in in front of
okay right exactly fine just to Define
what it is thank
you guys any comments or
concerns okay is everybody in general
support of the idea itself so we've gone
through the nitty-gritty of it but
anyone have any concerns of the concept
of the peer support
groups all right if there's no further
conversation in it I would entertain a
motion from the
subcommittee your motion a to pass okay
so the motion is a to pass Amendment
1096 do I have a second thanks
friend um all in favor of adopting the
amendment
4 okay and someone like to make the
motion other than me for a to pass with
Amendment thanks bra do I have a second
thanks Steve um all in favor right
forp
okay um last one um thank
you me get there
[Music]
13 1385 representative Brown's here so
representative Brown did you want to
walk us through the
amendment uh sure thank you Mr
chair uh we we worked uh through a few
questions at the
subcommittee last
Friday um I believe as I I looked at
this I I looked at it Monday but on page
one on line 15 and 16 I thought we were
going to take out commenor training
experience and military occupation
especially is determined by oplc because
it appears later in the amendment so I'm
pretty sure that was supposed to come
out but I don't know that it's a
problem having it in there because
that's where I had put it but
uh uh the attorney had moved it
um so uh pretty much on on page one that
was the only change that change that had
been
made
um it doesn't really affect the it's not
going to have a negative impact on the
legislation all if you look at page
three it's on line 10 11 and 12 it says
they will determine what that means
under 332
G7
one one
um on page two on line 15 we tossed
around the idea to make sure that this
bill did include
veterans because it wasn't listed on
page on three ABCD on page three but on
page two we decided to put veterans into
the title on line
15 changing it from an spouse or
temporary lure
to make sure veterans was in there uh
the attorney had
put military service members and their
families and Veterans and representative
Simon had some concern about what did
and families mean which I think is fear
so I changed that back to military
service members spouse and Veterans and
I haven't heard any uh throwback from
the attorney on that there was real
quick a question on that um
when you go down another line um and
maybe this isn't a concern maybe it's
just automatically included because it's
in the title but it says the office of
professional lenser and certification
shall issue temporary licenses to a
member of the Armed uh forces or their
spouse once again veterans isn't listed
there is that necessary or is member of
the Armed Forces adequate oh um uh the
AG in general might be able to answer
that better but I think on his face said
he wanted to say something
so yeah
please and he may be able to clarify I I
think uh page page page two lines 16 and
17 I know that there's uh sometimes a
difference in the language between
active members and Veterans and I just
want to make sure that what is listed
will cover the veterans because that's
kind of the point right I I think that
that temporary lure was more to to
handle when active military members are
going in their three-year change over to
a different base that they can more
easily get a license for their spouse
yeah so representative I I think I think
if you look at 310 I'm not sure for for
sure I think it's okay okay you look at
31016 specifically talks about uh the
portability of licenses for military
members who are transfering into the
state so I think we addressed a veterans
piece earlier in this part of the
legislation so I think it's really two
different things I'll I'll read this
really comprehensively while you
continue to talk to make sure that
that's the case but I know 31016 talks
specifically about portability of
licenses for spouses who follow their
their military uh member into the state
based on orders right so I think that's
what that deals with so I think we're
okay in that particular section I'll
look to make sure veterans are covered
in other parts of the bill give me a few
seconds Mr chair your program looks like
it Deals Only with
veterans
so uh Mr chair yes so I think uh in in
one of the iterations so
unpaid where you were on on uh line 16
has changed to Roman numeral one and
then on page three on line three no
Roman numeral 2 is added to that section
of the
law and I had added e on there in one of
the iterations where I just put veterans
and attorney uh from oplc took that out
and I think we talked about this that
the they felt that putting veterans in
the title was adequate for that I I
would kind of like to see an e in there
that says veterans
yeah
okay yeah uh once again if you're
comfortable with it and you think it's
going to accomplish it I'm I'm fine with
it I just wanted to make sure that was
the only thing when I was rereading
through it that kind of jumped out at me
as potential problem to verify I don't
see an issue with it I mean and and
again some of this will be addressed in
the administrative rules at oplc I don't
I don't want to speak for director
Courtney or or uh or or the
attorney but some of it will be
addressed in the administrative rules
piece and specifically the RFP that
they're working so that to rewrite the
rules will have significant input into
that that piece U yeah we just need to
make sure we've given them the pieces to
do it so y think so
okay anything else representative
Brown uh no I think just for uh
representive Maguire's
edification 332 G7 Roman numeral 1 we
did have a change that in this amendment
and it got taken
out that requires all boards
to make rules regarding crosswalks Andor
matrixes matrices which according to
director Courtney either hasn't been
done or it's not anywhere near complete
hasn't been done would be my guess okay
so she originally had put in an
amendment at at the end of this
amendment she originally had put in that
this amendment
would have oplc do all the rul making
for that Matrix
creation for boards that are under oplc
and then I said what about the ones that
aren't EMS really specifically M and we
decided that the
subcommittee because that was a late
introduction that we couldn't throw that
into the amendment now because those
boards wouldn't have known about this so
uh adant Deputy adant General said he
would be willing to bring that to the
Senate and we could try to do that as an
amendment in the
Senate if just just again I give you the
history of that so all of that has
removed that makes I think that's what
we talked about and that makes sense
right is what we talked
about I think the um EMT licensing is
it's
National so there should be a good uh
understanding of what the military
training is I hope so you're you're
correct if you if you if that was a
question you are correct so on the Army
side if you are a combat medic you're
licensed in the National Registry of
EMTs and whether or not the state grad
you know grants that license and they
should if they're in the National
Registry there are caveats you have to
continue your cus there's some other
things to maintain that lenser but you
are correct
represent Mr chair when I first started
researching this I did talk to
a bureau chief at EMS whose Name Escapes
me and he did say that there there there
is that some of that direct crossover
but that only applies to military
members who are able to or required to
get a national certification which many
of the Medics are not still and if I
understand that correctly so not not all
Medics are maintain that military
occupational specialty so there are some
FLOTUS for example wouldn't necessarily
be you know a combat medic and maintain
that EMT certification there was there
are some other caveats there but they
could be licensed to be FLOTUS it just
they would don't need a license to be a
flomist I'm sorry there's no license
required to be a flomist I'll draw your
blood a little later
representative nice seriously that's
something that the whoever hires you is
responsible for making sure you're
trained it's not a not a state
license uh any other comments or I think
that's pretty much I think that's pretty
much everything we talked about I'm I'm
I'm happy with it the way it is as long
as page one line 15 and 16 attorney
uster and yeah and director Courtney are
okay with that being D duplicative kind
of I right see it's a problem that's um
yeah I mean that's the kind of thing we
might be able to pull out later or in
the Senate so since we're going to have
to amend it anyway I think the um like
um maybe
um whatever I I don't think it's
necessary but I don't think it's a
problem yeah well we're not we're not
going to touch it anyway that'll be
something they have to do on the other
side of the wall I suppose if they want
to well if you simply wanted to delete
it we could get a we could get a quickly
revised
Amendment but if we don't if you're
you're happy with it we can just leave
it
there for example where you could keep
your your training as a FLOTUS and show
it to the
hospital or the Red
Cross there you go the only thing I'll
say is that that U the attorney had
moved that out in one one of the
iterations and I'm not quite sure how it
well we had a few going around so they
got yeah yeah you've got to got to keep
your eye on them just for clarification
we're talking about the other boards not
covered by oplc is that what we're
talking about now we're talking about
something different no we're on page one
under the definition of license yeah it
was commensurate training and and the
oplc had taken that out it doesn't have
to be I don't think it has to be in here
are you more comfortable if we strike
it I'm comfortable with whatever will
make this go through if if we strike it
in the Senate that's but this is
describing what the veteran the VAP is
doing yeah all right and they may be
able to say oh yes you've got your fotus
certification in New Hampshire you don't
need a license you're good I think or
even more appropriately electricians for
example we passed some registration last
year about experiencing electricians to
surpass their apprenticeship period
right so the vlap would be able to say
this is what the law says this is what
your training says you should be able to
go to the board and make this this go so
I think it's I think it's important to
have it spelled out in both places I I
don't I don't think it's I don't think
it hurts anything for it to be clarified
yeah it's not I don't think it's hurting
anything for sure
okay and and then I'll just reiterate do
we want to add on page three under Roman
numeral 2 do we want to put an e for
veterans so that Roman numeral 2 falls
under three
uh P line 15 on page
two but it doesn't say veterans and I
had put it in there and and oplc said
they didn't need it but I don't think
it's this section says that they shall
facilitate and if there are I think that
it's nice to include it would be
appropriate to include veterans and the
ones that say go to the head of the
line which is essentially what that does
yeah um I'm I'm good with doing that do
you want to take on the responsibility
of getting it in there before exec yeah
or can we I mean we could push this back
to next week too if we need we would
really we've got a couple of big ones
pushed back to next week so I would
really rather get it done get a simple
one line change yeah so we can I mean we
can we can recommend it with knowing
that the line change is coming and then
we'll just have to look at the final
version Oh add that as e you think or
yeah y okay and sounds okay on your sure
yeah it's just just clarification
everybody's happy everybody's happy I
think are you guys happy all right I'll
will entertain a motion then on
109h all right I've got a motion about
to pass on Amendment
109h the second thank you very much any
further discussion all in favor
40 all right I will move out to pass
with
Amendment do I have a second
Senator Davis thank you all in
favor 4 all right we'll bring these
recommendations guys thank you so much
for your time and we'll see you in a
half an hour it's an hour I think oh was
it is it at 10:30 or we have caucus uh
it's it 10 oh sorry I thought it was at
10:30 sorry no
there's
e
e all right good morning welcome um we
have rep some substitutes today
representative Howard is in for
representative
O'Brien representative harb I
believe K Hill excuse me representative
K Hill is in for representative
Gard I believe representative U
represent Dolan okay represent geard is
not going to be here and we have
representative McDonald is supposed to
be covering for him so I hope he will
show up shortly our representative
santonastaso has said he'll he is coming
in a few minutes
late
and I'm hoping to get all of these bills
exec today with the possible exception
of 1095 where the amendment is not yet
updated representative McDonald how nice
to see
you you're in for representative
Gard so committee reports are due are
should be in today so I hope I've gotten
up drafts from a number of people so
they should be ready and uh we will see
what we can
do
all
right some sore here uh how about we
start with Daylight Saving Time
representative uh ghoul do you have have
a motion thank you madam chair I have a
motion to to um
approve amendment that I just passed out
and where did I keep my copy thank
you amendment number
um 20 oh amendment number
0572 which amends the bill to um
basically I'll just read my little blip
wait a minute wait a minute you made a
motion to adopt the amendment yes we
need a motion to adopt the amendment
I'll I'll second the motion so that's by
G seconded by representative groda you
wish to speak to your amendment I
presume I do Madam chair thank you very
much
um the amendment
turns the bill into uh a bill that would
provide New Hampshire that New Hampshire
shall exempt itself from daylight
savings time when authorized to do so by
the United States Congress and this
committee knows we've had many many
bills over the years before my time even
for um making this change people don't
like the time change and they want it to
change we heard a lot of testimony that
we need to stay in step with the states
that border us for reasons of work and
and family life and for lotss of
different reasons so um I did a little
research and found that the states are
coming together 11 states have already
passed bills main being one of them that
would make the change when Congress
authorizes the states to do so so I got
this amendment drawn up to uh
representative Horgan who submitted the
original Bill supports the amendment and
uh I think this will put New Hampshire
in the queue with the States in line
with our bordering state of Maine to um
make the change when Congress approves
it right representative BR do you wish
to speak to your second no thank you
okay is there any comment from anyone
questions on the
amendment representative meny thank you
madam chair it the amendment replaces
the entire Bill correct correct correct
thank
you okay any other
questions
comments all right then the motion is to
adopt amendment
0572 to House Bill 1075 and the clerk
can call the
role represent Simon yes represent
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes representative
K yes representative
McDonald yes votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown yes
representative Gro yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Howard yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative manery yes and
the chair yes 19 y0
a okay is there a motion on the mo the
amendment passes is there a motion yes
I'd like to move the we um that we
pass how ought to pass with with
Amendment correct thank
you I'll second
okay and you wish to speak to your uh
your new motion I think I said
everything previously Madam chair okay
repr gr I agree with representative G
okay I'd like to say that it's very very
elegant because it's much simpler to say
when Congress tells us we can we will
instead of trying to petition
Congress which we would have to do
repeatedly yes and just to um clarify I
believe 11 states have already done this
so there is a nationwide group that's
tabulating these bills across the
country and Congress will hear what the
people are wanting them to do thank you
and I I will say this was the first time
we've had a similar Bill where we did
not have to beat up on the fact that the
time changes are stressful and dangerous
because everybody agreed to that so it's
it was a nice touch all right any other
comments questions Madam chair yes yes I
I think uh long-term members of this
committee realize that uh I have opposed
this idea for many years um dependent on
the fact that I felt it should be
Nationwide so I find myself able to
support
this thank you any other
comments all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 1075 and the clerk can
call the role representative Simon yes
representative leakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative kahill yes
representative McDonald yes CL V yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative SM
schit yes representative goalie
sorry yes representative Shu yes
representative Howard yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 19 y0 N all right the
motion passes 19 to Z any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that one on
consent let's see how about House Bill
1079 man
uh I'm not sorry I'll talk about not
1079 I have some amendments to pass out
so I'll wait for to House Bill 1079 no
oh
okay do we not have do we have an
amendment to 1079 yes you should have
it well for discussion I'll move the
amendment to um
1079 all right
second who G okay which am which one
there are two it's Amendment 1096 H I
believe it's my Amendment
yeah yeah I'll talk to them but you need
a
copy yeah this is amendment 1096 H by
representative
Simon represent BR you don't wish to
speak to it well I would like to ask
representative Simon to speak to it
since it's his Amendment and I did this
only to start the
conversation okay representative
G um I I'm interested to hear what
representative Simon has to say all
right representative Simon you're on I
apologize to the Comm for my tardiness
let's jump in um thank you for moving
the amendment in seconding uh so this
deals with critical incident stress
management teams uh it's a peer support
group um that uh was in um Public Safety
or emergency response and Public Safety
workers allowing people who have gone
through a traumatic experience to talk
to one of their colleagues as opposed to
going to professional um counselor who
may or may not understand the
complexities of of what they deal with
out in the field um so uh the original
bill was one line it came to us uh as a
five-page Amendment so it was sent to
subcommittee so that we could look at it
more in depthly um I'll just point out
real quickly to the changes um on page
two line three we've added a definition
for emergency sponse Public Safety
worker and everybody who falls under
that category simply so that as it comes
up in the rest of the statute uh you can
refer back to this and know exactly what
it is that we're talking about it gets
rid of the ambiguity um the second thing
of notes starting on line nine um this
was the main purpose they originally
brought the bill for they wanted to make
sure that uh emergency hospital uh
Hospital Emergency Department Personnel
were covered uh under this kind of
agreement and uh so I've adjusted the
language a little bit it now says
Hospital Emergency Department Personnel
means staff rendering care rescue
support and life- saving Services while
working for Andor in the hospital
emergency department uh representative
schmith that was primarily for your
concern that if they were outside of the
space they would still be covered so
you're welcome so that's in there
um let's see uh on line 25 of page two
um it talks about um the CR
International critical incident stress
Foundation which would set um the
certification standards and also uh
maintain training um requirements uh I
added in on line 25 and also the
commissioner of safety since we're
covering the in statute I felt like it
was only reasonable that there should be
somebody some government entity that
oversaw what they were doing and not
just some other organization and uh we
talking with everybody the commissioner
of safety seems like the appropriate
person um to just make sure that what's
going on um there's some accountability
there um and secondarily then
accountability to us so um line 28 they
wanted to make sure that members who uh
were a part of these teams could be
retired um Public Safety
workers um so that they could continue
to to be helpful so that was added in
there
so and then at the end of the amendment
um they
took what was uh deemed to be
confidential uh and they flushed that
out to a greater degree so the the
principles are are similar uh just with
more detail uh so that was already in
statute but they wanted to add some
distinctives to it so that's flushed out
there the subcommittee thought that the
changes were reasonable and helpful um
and so we bringing it to the full
committee with its recommendation to
pass questions comments concerns
represent V thank you madam chair um
just a question about uh page three uh
line 21
to 35 The Suicide
Prevention um is this applicable to all
emergency respond ERS that are
responding to a call from a
distressed First
Responders thank you for the question
representative so this um this section
just deals with what will not be deemed
confidential uh when they're talking
with each other so if any of these
things are brought up um in one of their
meetings and there's a question about it
um they will have to divulge that
information um because it's too it's too
important that people would be able to
respond to it so that's that's all that
that deals with thank you
yep representa I just want to make sure
so in line nine and 10 did you change
the definition of the hospital emergency
department personnel uh thank you
representative yeah we um ju I just
adjusted uh let me get there um so on
line 10 you'll see that it says for
Andor in that was the only change and
the reason we made that change uh
originally it was in the hospital
emergency department and there was some
concern from the subcommittee that
somebody who worked for um the emergency
department would be outside of the
department at the time that they
encountered the incident trying to help
and that they would not have access to
these services so I just changed it to
say that if you're working for the
hospital emergency department or in
Andor in the hospital emergency
department then you would have access to
these
Services thank
you yeah I'd like to add to that this
would also cover other Hospital
Personnel who were called into emergency
as might be the case if there was a a
disaster that wanted all the help they
could get so your your other staff might
be working in the emergency department
and would be covered would be able to
deal with a a critical incident stress
team anyone
else okay the motion is to accept
Amendment 1096 H to House Bill 1079 and
the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
kahill yes representative McDonald yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20
a0 okay is there a
motion assignment thank you madam chair
I'll move a to pass with
amendment is there a second second okay
that's by Simon seconded by Schmidt do
you wish to speak to your motion uh no
thank you madam chair representative
schm I think this is uh there's been a
lot of work on this very well crafted
we've tried to include virtually
every kind of situation that we could
conceive of uh and to protect these very
important people um being exposed to in
very serious stress so I think this is a
very good Bill thank you other comments
questions all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 1079 and the clerk can
call the role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon staso
yes representative K yes representative
McDonald yes clerk votes yes
representative voyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 2a0 n all
right the motion passes 20 to Zer any
objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
this on
consent Madam chair can I take a few
seconds to distribute the amendment to
uh for a different bill that we are
going to be exacting all right later
okay thank you we'll take take
amendments uh I think we should take up
House Bill
1474 which was deferred to
today uh we had a motion of interim
study by representative
gold representative gold yes Madam chair
I would like to resend my motion and I
have some comments on that I can give
those now or wait until after after we
get another motion so we know what we're
doing uh representative Schmidt you have
a motion I move I move on to pass on
House Bill 1474 is there a
second second representative G by
representative G okay representative
Schmidt you wish to uh speak to your
motion I do Madam ch thank you very much
uh colleagues uh this bill is brought on
behalf of the uh New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs uh
which has been uh working on uh the
amendment for some time with regard to
um facilitating their ability to
function which has been hampered by the
fact that they uh do not have a fully
appointed membership and there for
Quorum has been very difficult for them
to obtain that's a and and this will
hopefully alleviate that
situation um and uh a couple of other
you know
um aspects where we have struck out um
some existing federal statute I believe
someone may be able to speak to this
that we have some people from the
commission here this morning uh if they
they uh would be allowed to confirm um
that some of the federal statutes uh are
out of date um and
so that has been worked on and I'm not
sure exactly I know that um Ben uh
Wilson from the Department from the
agency said he would attempt to be here
today I don't know whether he's been
able to make it or not because I don't
know him personally
but uh
I guess he's not here okay um thank
you madam chair that's enough do we have
copies of
that what it's it's the original bill
it's
147 there's no
yeah sorry I I quite understand your
confusion but occasionally we do pass a
bill without
Amendment all right representative G
thank you madam chair I just wanted to
say that um I've made the motion
originally for interim study because of
some concerns about um the future as we
move forward this committee as people
know passed a a bill for a study
committee and so I was concerned about
any possible inconsistencies with uh
approving a bill this year and then next
year study committee coming back with
different recommendations and I've been
assured that that won't be an issue and
I'm really happy to support the work of
the commission and look forward to the
work together to uh to move
ahead I think the the largest part of
this bill is essentially establishing
the Quorum and the membership such that
the commission can work and the study
committee is to evaluate what it's
working on and that can be done while
the commission um proceeds with the
trink or
business anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is ought to pass by representative
Schmidt on House Bill 1474 and the clerk
can call the RO representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative saso yes
representative kill yes representative
McDonald yes CL votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative Howard yes
representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative G yes representative
Smith yes representative manuti yes and
the chair yes 20 a0 and
a all right does anyone object to
consent it pass 20 to
Z all right seeing no no objection we'll
put that on
consent all right house bill
1420 that one I thought we had voted on
already but it's not in the system so I
would like to get it revoted on
representative Brown you had a
motion uh my recollection is I I would
make a motion for interim
study that's mine also I'll second the
motion
do you wish to speak to your motion uh
just as a reminder this was a bill to
have state agencies call anyone that was
in contact with them call them back
within three days and we had quite a bit
of discussion about how complicated that
could get but it wasn't a bad idea to
make sure agencies were providing
adequate public service so the interim
study was uh proposed Madame chair we
seem to have a disagreement in that we
have people here who have a vote count
from February 14th it was not okay it
was not included in the somehow it never
got in so it was not included into the
official it's not did somehow it didn't
get into the official record
so I presume representative goalie that
the vote was in fact pretty much
unanimous for interms St it was 1521 I
had representative Gro to make the
motion representative Le a second and
this was done
214 and put on consent I
agree yeah my record shows that to fine
I thought so myself but it's okay so
what do why don't we do it again either
that or just vote to confirm that vote
that since we'd already did it um then I
would uh resend my motion that's okay
it's the the same result I believe and
and Madam shair as we know all these
hearings are recorded So it's very easy
for somebody to go back pull the tape on
the 14th to see that we did do this so
I'm not sure how I got lost in the
paperwork
but I guess things happen and it's
probably probably got sent in my spam
folder and uh but the good news is that
we keep the same vote so that's actually
we're very consistent right uh huh
yes I would say also if if we are going
to redo Would we not have to withdraw
the previous
vote that's
why
well Madam chair would you like a motion
well we have a motion we have probably
dozen motions Madam chair I I think we
should confer with the clerk's office
since it's a clear case that we that
represented there there you are Mi Mr
Greenland good
morning an issue has come up where House
Bill
1420 was voted
on on February
14th it doesn't seem to be in the system
we don't disagree with the previous
recommendation how do what do we need to
do now in order to get it into the
system
it was exec in
committee with a recommendation of
interim
study and we were only 15 16 that day 15
I believe that was the day of the
hearing yeah so if you could if you
could confirm exactly what it is we need
to do at this
point that's correct it is not in the
system as having happened but we have
our notes and our
memories thank you we will uh not do
anything more until we discover what the
easiest way to get this settled is
because there's no disagreement on that
one all right how about 1456 representa
groto you have a motion
yes I move aop pass on House Bill
1456 is there a
second I'll second okay seconded by
representative
Shu okay you wish to speak to your
motion I'd love
to so some of us might remember because
this is one of those bills
that can be difficult to remember
that it involved the board of tax and
land
appeals and that recommendations had
been made that in the bill rather than
the Supreme Court making the appointment
to the board of tax and lands appeal the
Supreme Court would vet the candidates
but that the appointments would be made
by the governor and the executive
Council and the reason why this was
important is that when the members are
appointed by the Su Court there really
isn't time there
isn't
uh the availability of public
opinion whereas in the when the when the
position is appointed by the governor
and the executive Council public opinion
is part of the process and so the board
actually supports this and um it made
sense to me that we should do it this
way so that the public has an
opportunity to um make opinion on who
the members of the board in tax and land
appeals are the other
um the questions that were that the
committee had I can go over them but
were very um process oriented and um
satisfied the bill does answer the
questions that we had so I would support
I would I would like the committee to
support the OTP motion of House Bill
1456 thank you representative shu
yes we did hear that um this board is
considered I think the term was quasi
judicial and therefore uh it seemed
appropriate for the appointments to be
made in this
manner okay any other comments represent
goalie thank you madam chair the only
question I have is and I'm looking back
at my notes Here was on line three
changing the appointment from three
years to five years was a recommendation
I don't know if that yes representative
yes that
well some people didn't care and some
people wanted to keep it for five years
for um
continuity but I didn't there was no
amendment to do
so I didn't I don't I don't have any I
have one person saying that they thought
five years was better and another person
saying that it didn't really matter to
them Madam chair I did have in my notes
that uh testimony was that prior to
2011 they had five-year terms so it's
not totally out of the realm of of
reliability I guess is the word I'm
looking for
okay
any do we wish do we wish to amend it
for fiveyear terms or or not bother
represent it is there any uh interest
representative
Schmid thank you madam chairman so uh I
serve on the board of um the assessing
Standards Board uh for some time I think
it's about 16 years uh and the board of
tax and land appeals is a very important
institution and kind of a special
special breed of cat but it could use a
little bit of of modernization which has
already been spoken to so I think this
is U we should proceed in this fashion
and this will benefit the stability and
also the continuity of the board of tax
and land appeals thank you thank you
other
comments all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
1456 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
kahill yes representative McDonald yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
gr yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manap py yes and the chair yes 2809
okay motion passes 20 is there any
objection to
consent seeing none
okay not something up
it's uh House Bill
1545 representative manip
py you just passed out an amendment so I
make an
amend I move to adopt the
amendment uh
224-1158 I'll
second okay representative man py do you
wish to speak to your motion um yes
thank you madam chair uh it just one
paragraph that was added to the original
bill in this uh Amendment and uh if you
remember uh this was at the hearing it
added um not
withstanding the blur from nine five n
line five to 10 so this just amends it
tad bit
so clarifies rather not Tad clarifies
the fact that when the sub of property
may be transferred and it uh clarifies
in RSA 204
DD
okay representative BR do you have a
wish to speak to your second I do thank
you so um Ben Frost from the New
Hampshire housing um mentioned that they
have the preemptive right to this um
State these State Properties but they
felt that Pro profit or nonprofit
organizations should be included in this
they should have the same availability
so I think that's what this this bill
does it gives them the right to do so um
and that was as a so this amendment came
forth from the recommendation at this
sub at the Committee
hearing okay any Madam chair another
clarification this was my goof up I had
the language and I was going to bring
the amendment and I
totally forgot about it until this
morning like yesterday so I got the
amendment in a rush so this specific
language was given by Ben Frost which
was uh you know housing trusts this is
exactly it clarifies so that's my fault
thank you other comments representa yeah
just for clarification this amendment
though because um it does take the New
Hampshire Housing bureau out of the
running because they're not a nonprofit
organization but he felt that it was
important to do so so um that just
clarifies that there's no motive or
hidden agenda behind their move
no uh no comment on the amendment I will
on the bill is
amended I just wanted to thank U Mr
Frost and congratulate him on his
election yesterday as moderator in
Warner and um am happy to support this
amendment that resolves some conflicts
that the original Bill had in
it
the motion is to adopt Amendment 1115 to
House Bill 1545 and the clerk can call
the role representative
Simon
yes represent lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative saso yes
representative kill yes representative
geard I'm
sorry McDonald's sorry my bad okay
representative McDonald yes clerk roach
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
Gould yes representative Smith yes
representative man JY yes and the chair
yes
280 all right we have adopted the
amendment is there a motion on the
bill I make a motion repres manager P
thank you madam chair I make a motion to
otpa uh HB
1545 second second by representative
gold all right do you wish to speak to
your
motion yes just a brief again
clarifying that it's uh on the original
Bill
3B that is replaced by the in the
amendment that's it okay thank you
representative gold no everything has
been said Madam okay representative luus
thank you madam chair um I have a
problem with this
and I have a concern where um things are
funded you not in an open manner I mean
if we're going to give money for um this
sort of thing I would say that the uh
property should be sold at fair market
value and then if the legislature
decides to provide money for um for
other things such as housing then that
should be done through a bill or the
normal budgeting process uh um I'm sure
the motive of everybody here is is fine
trying to help but it it seems to me
that it it looks like kind of a a way of
hiding spending um where it should be
more in the open at least if I
understand what this is doing
correctly represent Manti um there is no
money given for housing it is the sale
of the property on a surplus property uh
from my understanding uh this what the
Housing Authority has the prior dip and
not every property that's available for
development that the Housing Authority
can uh do it so they can partner uh with
with the housing crisis so it's the
properties Lee
or say the property exactly
representative leus you were wanted to
continue I understand that the issue is
if you sell something at less than fair
market value then you're foregoing uh
revenue for the state which is in a
sense the essentially the same thing as
as giving the money away uh to something
so that's why I have a problem with
it representative Simon you
representative gold thank you so much
Madam chair in my opinion this is not
mandating that the property be sold
below fair market value it simply is
allowing the flexibility for the state
to make choices that serve the situation
best on individual
properties repr Simon thank you madam
chair um perhaps this did go to
subcommittee no not exactly okay um my
original concern with the bill and
represent man P maybe you can speak to
this
um was that we're we're giving these
properties to a non-government entity at
below fair market value
and I I I think your Amendment here is
trying to deal with it my concern is
that you know this isn't in perpetuity
uh it's not a forever thing that they
have to hold these standards eventually
they're free and clear of the government
intervention and they can do whatever
they want with the property um did we
ever find out what that limitation was
like how long they have to keep to this
agreement before they can do something
else I would ask uh Ben Frost Mr benen
Frost if he could
ask the language came specifically from
the housing if that's appropriate Mr
Frost can you answer that uh uh
question thank you madam chair uh
committee members good morning
I'm Ben Frost I'm the deputy executive
director and chief legal officer at New
Hampshire housing uh we are in fact a
governmental entity we're an
instrumentality of state government
created by the legislature under RSA
204c uh back in
1981 uh regarding the term of
affordability it's not specific in RSA
204d which is the statute referenced I
believe in the amendment although I've
have not seen the amendment itself um
that is the The Sur Surplus lands
statute that pertains to affordable
housing that does not contain a a term
of
affordability thank you
representative yes on on lines uh End of
Line nine and line 10 is the reference
to RSA 204d that does not contain a term
of affordability U but generally the
projects that we Finance we don't build
the housing but we Finance developer
construction uh have terms that are at a
minimum of 20 years but typically are
more like 30
40 uh 60 sometimes 77 75 years of
affordability representative Simon thank
you uh thank you for taking my question
so what what's the determining Factor as
to whether it's 20 30 40 77 like how do
you make those distinctions between
applicants thank you for the question
the the answer depends on the other
sources of funding so for example uh if
we were to use the state's affordable
housing fund that has a statutory
minimum term of affordability of 20
years um if we were to use the uh
low-income housing tax credit which is a
federal program that we administer uh
that tends to be a minimum of 30 years
although we push that to 40 and 60 years
depending upon the type of tax credit
used uh we're now giving incent we we we
will be giving incentives to developers
in the next next round to push that up
to 75 years um it it these are typically
um financially complex transactions that
have a deep Capital stack many different
sources of funding and whichever one has
the longest term of affordability is the
one that
controls other do are there any other
immediate questions for Mr Frost before
we let them
go
back so this might help a the concerns
of of the of some of the members of the
committee if the um if this property is
used for affordable housing is there a
restriction that the you know after the
the property cannot be sold for profit
by the organization after a certain
amount of time is there restriction of
what they can do with the property so
that the concern is obviously that they
buy it for a low price and then they
sell it for a high price and walk you
know so is is there how can we alleviate
that
concern thank you for that question
representative the I think the best
answer I can give is that we uh
maintain um control over the operations
of these properties we don't we don't
administer them directly but we oversee
them on behalf of and in collaboration
with other investors uh so typically
speaking these are uh
for-profit um developments even when
they're done by a nonprofit entity and
this this relies on a provision of the
low-income housing tax credit which
requires the development to be owned by
a for-profit entity even if it's a
nonprofit that's behind it and that's
just an aspect of federal law uh so
these do these do make profit but we
require them uh in most cases to turn if
they spin off cash we require 50% of
that to come back to us which we then
reinvest in other properties um but we
maintain long-term Asset Management as
long as we have uh an interest in the
property for those terms as I earlier
described uh we are overseeing it and
that means uh deeded uh deed restricted
uh conditions that are recorded in the
registry of
deeds okay represent Brown and the M py
uh thank you madam chair uh thanks for
taking my question I can't find it in my
notes and I can't remember can you
refresh my memory on on why that the
Housing Authority wouldn't want to take
possession as you were allowed
to well I'm uh it's an interesting
question and I'm I'm my comments on this
at the hearing and here are in response
to the bill um we do have existing tools
under RSA 204d and other statutes to do
similar things uh this is um I'd say
helpful language that is intended I
think to guide state agency action and
uh long range and GNC as
well repr man py thank you madam chair
um isn't this the way of
uh Surplus property or uh not uh tax uh
Revenue generating property is
redeveloped and over a period of time
that would uh generate
taxes uh for the local community so this
transforming non tax generating property
into uh tax generating
property that's very correct representa
magy the almost all of the developments
that we Finance are uh taxable uh
properties so they pay local property
tax including the State education
property tax
so I I want to confirm something I
remember from the hearing that you
already have have a priority in the
purchase of such Surplus land but you
must pay full
price Madam chair it depends on who the
controlling agency is and the source of
funding for the state agency to have
acquired the property uh under RSA
204d uh we do have uh priority uh access
to it essentially a right of first
refusal to any state agency property uh
and we under that statute we can acquire
those properties uh I think the the
language of the statute is with without
consideration meaning without the fee
being paid for the value of the land so
we can under that statute acquire
properties uh without paying for them
subject to long range n&c that they're
they're the ultimate Arbiters of this
that's the existing statute so this the
existing statute says that you that you
can be given a chunk of surplus land
with the consent of the agency that owns
it and governor and counsel and long
range yes and long range planning and
this bill simply says if there's other
Surplus
property you can get it for below
Market correct so it expands your
options it does all right and I would
say specifically with regard to the
Department of Transportation that's
that's who owns a large portion of the
Surplus type land in the state as I
would imagine representative leus and
then Simon thank you it's just trying to
get some clarification on on what was
just asked
so um there was a reference to
Department transportation are they not
an agency that you can acquire Surplus
land from for no fee um I guess the
question is why would you want this if
you can just take the land without any
cost representative like I said it gets
to the the point I I made um in the my
prior response um and I didn't fully
answer the the question I think um with
regard to the Department of
Transportation it does depend upon the
source that the the dot used to acquire
the property on behalf of the State uh
so if it is federal funding then under
current federal law subject to waivers
uh then the current fair market value
must be obtained if it is highway or
Turnpike funds um I believe it is
uh the original purchase price and then
there may be other other ways too but
this this really gives some flexibility
to dot in particular in uh determining
that how they want to dispose of the
properties yeah I just looked at RSA 204
and it says Surplus property with
Highway fund shall be transferred to the
authority provided the authority shall
compensate the department for such land
and an amount acceptable to the
department
so so the idea that current Law requires
you to pay full market value is not
exactly correct okay followup followup
please so I the second part of my
question was um and I sort of got an
answer but I'm not entirely clear on it
is um you know what's the advantage to
your agency of having this rather than
just what you have today IDE and when
you say flexibility I'd like a little
expansion on that and uh the chair cited
um RSA 204d I think you also need to
look at um RSA 440 and I think there's
another statute maybe
439 uh and that there's a series of
statutes under 4339 ABC and I forget
which one is which uh but there
different terms that apply um different
requirements that apply depending upon
the the s source of funding that dot
used to acquire uh those properties this
would uh impact upon those whereas we to
give us well to give the agency uh
greater flexibility and I would suggest
guidance to um long range and and GNC
that it's within statutory authority to
do this thank
you representative Schmidt and then gold
thank you madam chair so
Ben can you tell us is this is this a
situation that's happening all the time
all over the place or is this a fairly
uh uh Arcane uh and unusual
situation well representative Schmidt
it's it's certainly Arcane but uh it is
um becoming increasingly common uh in
fact we are working with the Department
of Transportation right now uh regarding
properties in Conway that were
associated with the now defunct Conway
bypass project uh and this the
department is is disposing of those
properties we are preparing to pay full
fair market value for those we have uh
the department has an appraisal we have
an appraisal we haven't agreed upon
price um and and that that simply means
that it's a cost that's going to get
embedded into the the transaction that
when the uh properties are used for
development so you it seems to be a more
thank you mam chair so it seems to be
something that is coming more into
common practice uh
or I think so yes and I I'll just say we
have an excellent working relationship
with the Department of Transportation
okay I think that's helpful thank you
representative leus thank you so to to
help me decide what I'm going to do um I
do not
support you know having umone money go
into a program through any path other
than the legislature you know explicitly
providing it so the question is with
this bill will your agency be able
to expand um you know the program where
you can acquire property for this
purpose for less than fair market value
believe so okay thank you representative
gold thank you madam chair I have a
two-part question the first part is
if I remember correctly when the bill
was originally
introduced this bill was not your idea
you didn't ask for this bill is that
correct that is correct when you saw the
bill you worked with the representative
to um to work out some inconsistencies
with other parts of the law that is
correct thank you and followup Madam
chair
followup got it
sorry
okay all right representative Simon
thank you madam chair sorry for all of
the questions but appreciate your time
being here um the amendment that you're
looking at before you having worked on
the language of the representative to
iron out some of that does this
amendment F uh adjust any of the things
that you
fixed I believe representative this is
the language that I prepared and shared
with representative cluer okay very good
and follow up Madam chair follow um my
my last question I believe is uh we're
talking under fair market value what is
the range of under fair market value
does that go all the way down to zero
or okay so we're talking anywhere from
zero to fair market value yes thank you
very much okay anyone any other comments
represent Brown uh thank you madam chair
um and thank you for taking my question
U I'm sure the rest of you know this but
I don't uh is affordable housing defined
specifically
somewhere that's an excellent question
representative um and I'd say it is
defined in ah well it's right here right
line eight um RSA 204c col 56 Roman 1 uh
there is a statutory definition that is
the affordable housing fund statute and
that has a very clear and specific
definition of affordable housing thank
you and I apologize to you and everyone
here at the
table thank you for your apology any
other comments
I think I'd like to have a short caucus
on this so with uh your permission we
will
uh why don't we leave why don't we go
into the office and leave everybody else
here
e
all right thank
you
all right any any further comments
concerns representative
Shu motion yes the window will be closed
and then reopened later on when it gets
too
hot
okay so the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment House Bill 1545 and the clerk
can call the
role representative Simon no
representative Lakers no representative
Bailey nay Representative saso no
representative kill no representative
McDonald no clerk V votes no
representative Boyd
no representative Brown no
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Howard yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair
no 10 yay 10 nay all right the motion
fails on a tie does someone wish to make
an different motion represent saso uh
make a motion of itl for House Bill 15
45 a
second I'll second
it okay do you wish to speak to your
motion uh yes thank you madam chair so
this kind of thing uh is disagreeable
because it uh obscures costs for one so
that will cause uh confusion for
property values and pricing for the
market which uh prices provide valuable
information uh for all sorts of things
and uh as Tony was mentioning before it
sort of transfers funds from one
Department to another without uh going
through the legislator and kind of OB
scures the funding in that
way
okay anyone
else all right the cler and call the
role for the expected 101
vote representative Simon yes
representative L yes representative
Bailey yes representative Sasso yes
representative k yes representative
McDonald yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes Representative groa no
representative Schmidt no representative
goalie no representative Shu no
representative Howard no representative
Davis no representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould no representative
Smith no representative man py no and
the chair no ten ten oh sorry yes
I knew what I knew what she was going to
say pardon me that was a slip of the
tongue I meant to vote Yes for the ETL
forgive me thank you for counting it
that way because I knew what and here I
thought we knew how to vote on a
partisan
[Music]
basis thank you we held upheld our part
yes thank you representative Schmidt and
thank everyone for doing as expected
except for me I love how how friendly
our partisanship is
uh so this I believe will go to the the
uh floor without recommendation
representative maputi will write the
motion the the report in favor of all to
pass with Amendment representa Anon naso
will write the report for in expedient
to
legislate and we'll have
fun all
right uh let's do some something a
little more conial represent House Bill
1352 representative Simon do you have a
motion or it's the one on L on your
committee thank you madam chair I would
like to move Amendment
0981 I'll
second okay represent you wishes speak
to your motion thank you madam chair um
this bill deals with firefighter station
where or not to be confused with their
personal protective equipment which is
what they would use in an actual um
dangerous fire situation um station wear
is defined for the first time in statute
to differentiate it from personal
protective equipment so you can see that
on line 12 um there um further changes
the the amendment brings down on line
um the uh manufacturers have to um be
transparent as to whether or not the um
firefighter station wear contains past
chemicals um and those notices um on 30
line 30 says all notices shall be
included in all personal Personnel files
while employees using the firefighting
protective personal protective equipment
and a copy of the same shall be provided
directly to the employee so the employee
the employee has a record of whether or
not even the protective equipment that
they're using um has pasas in it um the
main change uh
is uh page two line nine and following
uh it says should safe alternative to
the current firefighter personal
protective equipment be designed and
manufactured fire departments may give
preference to that alternative as a part
of their existing personel protective
equipment replacement program and then
from 12 on talks about um a safe
alternative
um or sorry uh line 17 talks about the
station where uh This was um to address
representative Le's concern um um that
we're not um pushing an unfunded mandate
down um on the municipalities it gives
time um beginning in January 1st of 2025
uh for departments to cease um the
purchasing of that Fireware and then on
July 1st uh for the wearing of the same
um and that will allow uh the funds that
usually come for their allowance to come
through before they have to make those
purchases so that it's not um difficult
for the municipalities or for the
firefighter themselves so that's
essentially what the amendment does and
once again the subcommittee looked at
that thought it was reasonable and is
recommending it to the committee as
ought to
pass represent gr do you wish to speak
to your
second yes I um I think that the bill
the amendment
itself uh defines better the um the
intent of the bill however I do have a
question about this with representative
Simon
we're talking about in paragraph six
we're talking about station Weare which
I don't have a problem with that but in
paragraph five we're talking about
firefighting protective equipment yes
so I would how do we know that this
firefighting Personnel protective
equipment is approved by someone
is approved
by as approved by because you can you
know for example um one of the reasons
why these materials are used in fire
firing protective equipment is they
incredible tolerance to high heat and so
how do we make
sure
that this equipment when you
say they shall be given preference
a safe
alternative how do we Define this I just
want to make sure that someone doesn't
buy something that is considered safe
alternative and is less expensive and
isn't protecting our firefighters I mean
anybody can jump in on this conversation
because that's what concerns me I'll let
represent go hit it first and follow up
thank you madam chair there are
standards for which gear are certified
and made
acceptable for the turnout gear um and
that's what they would have to be using
when they set the standard they'd have
to follow those standards that are
already in place okay for the
gar standards are in statute not in
statute they're NFPA compliance okay all
right they in the fire code I support
the amendment and I um that was my only
concern but I do think that the bill
defines better the intent and I
appreciate the work thank you you're
welcome and just to clarify too uh the
bill also the amendment also States I
think both of them did um that they're
going to you know they shouldn't be
wearing that except when necessary but
obviously they still need to do it when
it's necessary but when they're out just
on a call that where they're not in
danger they shouldn't be wearing that
equipment because it's being proven to
cause cancer so we we don't want
that represent representative Schmid
thank you madam chairman we worked on
this in subcommittee a lot uh and I I
was at the W ugas Hospital C cafeteria a
couple of weeks ago and somebody
inadvertently triggered off a uh fire
alarm Okay and the the trucks we had
trucks from Dover and from Summers where
all came there was no fire but it was
interesting to see when they pulled up
see them getting out of the uh of their
truck and putting on their equipment
because you know they're not supposed to
wear it except when they're going in and
it's it's essential to protect them in
in an actual fire uh but otherwise they
don't want it on at all because it is
dangerous
okay so I called out to him saying there
ain't no fire guys take your time and so
forth but because otherwise they got to
get get into their gear and put it all
on and not wearing it when they're
driving
around good representative Brown uh
thank you madam chair uh for
representative Simon for clarify for me
it is it the the chemicals that could be
in the gear that can have been shown to
cause cancer in certain circumstances
not the gear itself that's not
necessarily is that necessarily proven
that the gear causes cancer um so
there's at least a a very strong concern
and correlation with the fact that the
past chemicals that they're presently
using as fire retardants in the gear um
is cancer causing because obviously when
they're in high heat and sweating pores
open up and you know there's a lot of
transfer between the chemicals and the
bloodstream um so we want to be cautious
of that this this bill in particular for
the most part is work uh dealing with
station wear station wear could be
t-shirts and you know pants or whatever
um stuff that they're just wearing
around the station and whatnot those
also have been Laden with past chemicals
um I think to just kind of consider it
as an extra layer of protection in case
they're not necessary I I did ask
whether or not it puts the firefighters
a greater risk to wear that under their
protective equipment and it does not um
so that's just to say this the regular
wear that they're wearing around the
station should have this stuff in it um
because they shouldn't be soaking in it
all the time yeah if anyone is
interested the uh Globe Manufacturing in
Pittsfield makes most of this equipment
and it's it's not just one layer it's
multiples and if you're interested we
can arrange for a
tour representative Gould and then Shu
it Madam chair just like to say again I
think I've said this before but the
conversations with this committee's
having and the testimony we heard have
spread out through so many networks kind
of backing up what representative
Schmidt said I know that volunteer
firefighters in my district are no
longer carrying pfast 3D gear in their
pickup truck riding around with it all
the time as a result of what we've
learned so thank you and I support well
that's very good representative Shu the
beny thank you madam chair yes um I just
want to point out and I I think we're
all aware that uh firefighting gear has
Chang changed and adapted over the I'll
say centuries technically uh as new
technologies come out that they think
will protect firefighters they're
adapted but unfortunately it sometimes
takes time and use to discover that some
of the materials are in fact uh
detrimental to the health of the the
very people that they're designed to
protect so any step forward that we can
take to try in advance that uh I think
is in the right direction okay represent
mani and then Schmid U thank you madam
chair um echoing some of the comments
earlier uh also realizing that PF uh p
is not only in the gear but also in the
insulation and stuff so from different
angles this is helping the
firefighters um First Responders going
into these fire to reduce the risk of
exposure in this personal gear my son is
a volunteer firefighter in Vermont and
this was very specific to asking the
volunteer firefighters to not use P
um uh cated uh pced uh um
clothing sorry and this was also um
initially it was also in the kids babies
the um what is it the pajamas and stuff
so this was uh you know but now a lot of
those things are retreating and I think
we are doing the right thing to protect
our fire
fighters representative Smith thank you
you recall those of us who've been
around for a while we had the
firefighting Foams the bill about 6 or 7
years ago they stuff used to be they
would the firefighters used to sometimes
use it in their graduation ceremonies
you know spraying it around dunking it
and so forth and so on and stuff turns
out to be extremely toxic and so forth
and so on much of that stuff has been
replaced by less harmful substances but
if you want to get true
protection you got to use it but you
don't want to be using it it except when
absolutely necessary to go into an
incident so this is what we're talking
about here okay yes represent gold one
last comment as a Shepherd I would be
remissed to not say there's some really
exciting research happening with wool
which is an old material but it can
provide Protections in a non-toxic
way representative
Brown um thank you everyone for that let
let me try to explain what I asked
representative Simon so because it seems
like some of you are concerned to what I
asked you go to the gas station there's
benzine and gasoline Benzene is a known
carcinogen but if you get a drop of
gasoline on your finger you don't get
cancer on your finger is my point so
that that was kind of what I was asking
thank you yes
they're over time these protective gear
has become less immediately toxic but
unfortunately it's still carcinogenic in
the long run
still beats getting
burnt all right anyone else comments all
right the motion is to adopt amendment
0981 to House Bill 1352 and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Sasso yes representative K yes
representative McDonald yes clerk votes
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes onea z n all
right is the amendment passes
go thank you madam chair I move on to
pass with am as amended with Amendment
okay seconded by representative Simon
moved by representative goalie ought to
pass with
Amendment do you wish to speak to your
motion yes
um as a
retired Captain with me just um I
understand the importance of turnout
gear and the protection it provides
also understand that in wearing that
turnout gear it also can be detrimental
to the health of some of the uh
individuals it's meant to
protect um so this is a big step in the
right direction to make sure that our
First
Responders are safe not only when
responding to a
call also while they are at the station
wearing uh their station where so for
those reasons I want to thank uh the
subcommittee and representative Simon
for putting together this amendment and
um support this okay represent
Simon um I think people have heard from
me enough today and I have a couple more
coming so we'll leave it for that all
right anyone else have a comment concern
question thank you representative Schmid
I'll hold you for that anyone else all
right the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 1352 and the
clerk can call the law representative
Simon yes representative leakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santonastaso yes representative kahill
yes representative McDonald yes Ro yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
man py yes and the chair yes 20 a0
n okay motion passes 20 is there any
objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that on
consent are
we
okay housei
1188 repres Smith you have a
motion Madam chair oh sorry it'sing my
mistake it's
me um
I make a motion to
adopt
Amendment uh 202
24-10
25h I'll
second
okay do you wish to speak to your
motion um yes Madam chair we did a lot
of work in subcommittee this is is to
pull the LNA licensing and application
and
processing um and
help reduce the cost for lnas by not
having
to pay for registry as well as
licensing
and speed up the process so the
amendment clarifies the only
uh attention I want to draw to uh draw
the committee to is um I think the
inconsistency in terms of the line
1819 where it says executive
director
and um again
under oh shoot there's another
place that is covered by the
other bill which is going to be
consistent it would be made more office
of
OPC so I'm okay with that all right
thank
you representative grer thank you um the
amendment excuse me in the original Bill
the amendment um I'm sorry in the
original Bill the fees were going to be
it said that the fees were going to be
established by the board and I apologize
because I did not catch that because the
fees are no longer established by the
boards and established by the office the
the uh the language was changed to
executive director which is fine and
other than that the bill is as the
original bill so I hope that the
committee will adopt the amendment and
adopt the Bill thank
you anyone else have a comment question
concern
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt the amendment
10 25h to House Bill 1188 and the clerk
from the RO representative zimon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative saso yes
representative kill yes representative
McDonald yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative gr yes yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative
goalie yes representative Shu yes
representative Howard yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative man JY yes and
the chair yes 20a z n right does someone
have a
motion I make a motion to adopt um to
passes uh amended HB 1188 FN is there
second
second that's represent goalie
good okay any further
discussion seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1188 and the clerk can call the RO
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative s saso yes representative
kahill yes representative McDonald yes
cler vot yes representative voyd yes
representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 2080 n all
right right motion passes 20 any
objection to consent it's an FN ma Madam
chair it's it's it's
not if I if I remember the fiscal note
it was very small and
indeterminable and so
it's uh we we'll put it on consent
unless it gets pulled for the for the
cost but I don't think that's the case
on this
one just want to mention
no she wrot motion oh yes um just to
confirm we we learned that since we
already voted on House Bill
1420 all that we have to do is get the
original committee report by
representative groda in and that should
solve the issue yes and I apologize the
committee for completely forgetting to
write the committee report which I will
do so today okay
well I'm glad to hear that because all
these repeated roller calls are wearing
me out I'll tell you that I was just
watching the audience thinking how
boring to just sit there staring at us
all all right well let's let's do a
couple more we have to explain the
Amendments House Bill
1131 I'll move to ought to pass and
present amendment number
1071 I'll
second so I'll mention that we heard
that there were problems the no the
original Bill simply
added clinics outpatient clinics to the
list of organizations that don't that
can employ unlicensed individuals for
mental health practice
after discussion in the subcommittee we
decided it wasn't really the
organization of
the agency that was doing it it was how
it would you know whether it's
for-profit or not for profit it's that
it's an organization that provides
services and provides clinical
supervision of its
staff so this Amendment instead of
adding to the list of Exempted
institutions Etc it says that the
organization provides clinical Mental
Health Services employs licensed
practitioners who can do the supervision
and provides clinical supervision and
assumes professional ethical and legal
responsibility for those
services so that is essentially what the
facilities or institutions or nonprofits
do this simply says we don't care if
you're for-profit or not you have to do
these things in order to be able to
bring
on unlicensed people people who are
waiting for their license and so uh we
think it will help with the problem of
for-profit and not for profit agencies
being treated
differently so representative
gr thank you for the excellent
explanation and I have nothing else to
add all
right anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
to adopt Amendment 1071 H House Bill
1131 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative
B yes representative saso yes
representative K yes representative
McDonald yes the clerk votes yes
representative voy yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitz Patrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 20 a0 n all
right motion passes 20 I move off to
pass with Amendment on House Bill
1131 I'll
second all right I don't think I need to
say anything repres
bro anyone else wish to
add represent man py thank you Madame
chair this will really help with the
Mental Health crisis and increasing the
providers in our state thank
you anyone else all right the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
1131 the clerk can call the RO
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon saso yeses kahill
yes representative McDonald yes clerk
vot yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
gr yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes yes
representative Shu yes representative
Howard yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 280 n all right motion
passes 20 any objections to
consent okay seeing none we'll put this
on
consent okay the other one is house Bill
1413 representative
Simon thank you madam chair I would like
to move Amendment
176 I'll second
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
uh yeah just real briefly um so all this
bill does uh is bring it in line with
the language that we just had in the
previous Amendment um in supervisory
agreements that go outside of the
realm of organization we on one-onone um
it simply states that the supervisor
shall assume professional ethical and
legal responsibility for the mental
health services provided by the
candidate in a written agreement on
record with the board there has been
some concern that the previous language
uh opened up the supervisor to legal
ramifications beyond their professional
uh engagement with um the candidate and
so we just wanted to clarify the fact
that they can only be held accountable
um when the candidate is providing
Mental Health Services
representative Bara I have nothing to
add thank
you anyone else questions comments
representative gold I'd just like to
thank the subcommittee for this I was
asked by my colleagues to report on it
yesterday and couldn't find anything and
at face value it looked very frightening
this is very simple and you made it very
clear and thank you for your
work anyone else represent VY again
thanks for doing this because this
enhances the providers in our state
which is much needed and increases the
pool thank
you anyone else all right the motion is
to adopt Amendment 1076 to House Bill
1413 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes represent Sasso yes represent
kale yes representa McDonald yes clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 280 name all
right there a motion thank you madam
chair I'd like to move a to pass with
Amendment on hp1 1413
is there a second second oh G
representative goul beat me to it all
right representative goul seconds the
motion do you wish to speak to your
motion no thank you madam chair
representative gold I think it's all
been said thank you okay anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
1413 and the clerk and call represent
Simon yes represent lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Sasso yes representative kahill yes
representative McDonald yes clerk votes
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
man jati yes and the chair yes 20 a0 and
a all right motion passes 20 to Z any
objections to
consent okay seeing none we'll put that
on
consent all right I think we will do
House Bill
1286 before launch representative Brown
you have a
motion what well
1286 the merger of the board of land
supervisors and um Professional
Engineers uh thank you madam chair yes
uh I move itl is there a second second
second by representative
gold okay do you wish to speak to your
motion um in the subcommittee we spoke
at at length about the the difference
between these two um professions and
that there would be some
significant addition in time probably to
the Board of Professional Engineers if
these two boards were combined and it
would probably be less efficient in the
long
run thank you representative gold my
colleague said it well okay any uh
representative
laus um thank you um yeah we decided
that that they are distinct enough that
the land Ser surveyor serving on the
board really couldn't help much with the
uh um you know the engineers and with
certain exception except for certain
exceptions the uh Engineers weren't
going to be able to come out on land
surveying combining them didn't make
sense in the future there are problems
with the number of land Ser surveyor
being small in the future it might make
sense to turn that into an Advisory
board but that's not the bill we had so
okay I support it
the anyone
else okay the motion is inex being to
legislate on House Bill 1286 and the
clerk can call the role representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
saso yes representative kahill yes
representative McDonald yes clerk vote
Yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes represent reprentative Howard
yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes represent man py yes and the
chair yes
okay okay House Bill
1385 Madam chair will that be going to
consent oh good question question motion
it passes 20 is there any objection to
consent
yes yes I think it will go to
consent do that all
right we'll do one we'll do one more
before lunch I've told some people i' do
the others after lunch so House Bill
1385 purpose of Simon do you have a
motion on that
one veterans licensing acceleration I'm
sorry
okay that that's Amendment uh 1090 yeah
I would like to move amendment
10968 is there a second yeah second okay
second by representative
Brown sorry when was this amendment
distributed we don't have it nobody has
it there may be some copies there
there's I would assume so I had a whole
bunch of them I apologize what's the
number of the amendment again
1090 I have
it I try again it was it incompletely
distributed this morning
1385 you can pass that down to somebody
actually I I I don't have one because I
gave mine to OS this
morning I can go prce them off this is
the bill wait a minute something this is
the wrong Amendment we're looking for
the amendment 10
n6h well it says it says amendment to
House Bill 1079 in
front I'm sorry I've misdirected the
committee this amendment right yes
that's why because representative Brown
is going to you're you moving this
you just did yes well you you can talk
to it though okay I can talk yes I can
move it and speak to it I apologize lot
of I know I'm so sorry I'll get i'll get
1079 for you when it comes off we have
1079 oh you don't have 1385 we don't
have 1385 oh that's right if I may catch
up with everybody that's because
representative Brown was going to go get
a change to it it hasn't come through as
far as I know so I have them it has not
I'm I keep checking my email and it has
not come through yet
okay Madam cheer would you like me to
talk about house buil tent oh we need to
withdraw the Motions I guess right if or
are we going to continue we don't have
the final
Amendment so so the the amendment change
is a um a minor detail that we can
discuss that doesn't change the bill at
all it's just a minor change to it so if
we want to discuss it we can and then if
you feel like it's too large of a change
we can withdraw it but I think we can
probably move forward I I don't have any
Amendment for we don't have any of the
Amendments oh he's got it
I I'd already passed it the other side
but I stopped
to Madam chair just a clarification if I
may
yes the amendment that was stated to be
offered was 1096 this is not so the
motion needs to be withdrawn 10 yeah
I'll remove my I'll remove my um motion
to move uh amendment 10 n6h because that
is what I moved and we'll I'll let
representative Brown make any further
motion all right this is amendment
1090 representative Brown moves the
amendment and representative Simon
seconds okay so just for clarification
if we vote on this amendment but then we
get another amendment it will have a
different number so how do we handle
that I just want to I think considering
the time we will discuss this amendment
the perspective change and if we need a
new Amendment we will have it back after
lunch okay that's
great at least give us time to go go a
lesson beat them over the head and
shoulders yes all
right
okay okay so everyone has Amendment 1090
which is the one the subcommittee voted
on this morning right right correct okay
representative Brown okay go ahead and
discuss is it is it is that what we're
doing yes all
right in the the original thank you
madam chair uh the intent of this bill
is fairly straightforward it's to help
veterans cross over to the civilian
world with licenses for whatever their
profession might
be in originally our thought as the
sponsors it was a team effort that we
could create a crosswalk and or a matrix
for all of the military occupational
Specialties over to civilian Specialties
and we quickly realized that that was a
a gantu and task and that none of us had
the expertise to actually do that job
I'm working closely with oplc and the
deputy agitant General Warren Perry from
the veterans
agency we massage the original Bill and
ended up with this amendment where we
are at now it creates a program in in
the veterans agency called the veterans
licensing acceleration program which
they will guide our veterans and uh uh
those that may be still in the military
but they know they're going to be
getting out very shortly it will guide
them through the process and help them
uh to work with oplc to get their
applications done
properly and oplc will then be able to
work for them to get their licensing
done
efficiently there we do have a small
concern that we're going to try to
address in the Senate because we we
brought I brought something up Friday
that would involve other the other
agencies whose boards are not under
oplc and they would not have been aware
of this amendment that we wanted to
bring
forward today so that will hopefully be
taken care of in an amendment when we
get to the Senate I think um
uh the veterans agency and Deputy
agitant General is is very much uh on
board with this as as he has left I'm
speaking for him is he still here no
he's not here he was here earlier um and
I think I that's probably enough um I'm
sure that uh representative Simon or
enals can chime in if you have any
questions I'm happy to take the
amendment that yes okay
so the amendment that I took down if you
go to page let's start on page
two on line 15 on page
two um under the SE existing section
31016 military service members we're
going to change that to spouse and
Veterans that's fine Roman numeral one
talks about the temporary
licenses which the intent was if you're
if you're a military person moving to
New Hampshire and your spouse has a
license as you you probably move every 3
years as a military person that your
spouse can easily get a temporary
license then it goes the addition is on
page three Roman numeral
2 and it says uh I'll read it
notwithstanding any journalist special
law to the contrary the executive
director s facilitate the issuance of a
license or certification for a person
and in that list
ABCD veterans is not stated we had some
discussion in the subcommittee that
because it say veteran back on page two
on line 15 that that would cover it but
we wanted to kind of make sure in
subcommittee this morning that it was
actually very clearly stated and I did
check with attorney AER how out in the
hall
subsequently um so we're going to add on
at line eight we're going to add
e which will and I was grammatically
corrected by the OS lawyer I had just
put veterans and he said if you read it
says shall facilitate the issuance of a
license or certification for a person
and he suggested who is a veteran and
may I believe it should be or is a
veteran because those other requirements
are
all take the hand out of
here and out of line seven and out of
line seven yep well no I mean the ABCD
are all requirements for a a trailing
spouse
essentially
anyway so it's not so simple
so or
yeah and as I haven't seen it yet I
don't know what he may have actually uh
come up with okay representative
representative
Simon oh um I was just saying yeah I
think you need an or there yeah an
e u I'd like to add that there's a
fiscal note here it is indeterminable
the agitant general has said that they
they're already responsible for doing
this work this just clarifies their
responsibility a little and they can do
it within their current budget the oplc
is already required
to uh facilitate licenses for military
and their spouses that's in current law
this again is mostly clarifying for
their point uh their responsibility the
um agencies that are not in oplc are
work are working with the veterans to
get their requirements in but the the
veterans agency oh me the
um is the one that has the knowledge of
what the military codes mean and how it
applies to civilian life and they will
be working with the individuals so that
they can get their license or in some
cases confirmation that they don't need
a
license and uh and that's already in the
bill anyone
else
1090 needs to be get
a at the moment representative Brown has
requested an amendment that adds in
veterans on page
three U but is otherwise identical to
this this amendment so we're not going
to be voting right
now it's in work
yes okay so is there any further
representative groa so I just want to
make sure on line
three I mean sorry on page three on line
seven is that an supposed to be an or is
it going to be an or in the in the new
Amendment No it should
be you would need to add an or after
right d so maybe since the oplc hasn't I
mean sorry since OS hasn't sent you
anything you might want to ZIP down
there and make sure they change the an
to the or because it certainly
makes
no yes A B C D all appli to the same
person who is getting uh facilitated
license okay okay all
right okay so sorry and then the E is an
or to the whole thing or a
veteran oh okay okay sorry yes I agree
yep
okay comments grammatical Corrections
uh representative
goalie
I just question the need for this
amendment when you look on page two line
15 specifically says in the heading
military service members spouse and
Veterans and all of this falls under
that heading so why do we need to add
veterans specifically if it's already
what this statute talks about that is
the question and if I
might thank you madam chair and
representative goalie uh I we had this
conversation subcommittee believe
attorney Oster how here and said the
same thing that because it's in the
heading we may not need it I was
concerned that it it appeared to be left
out in this list and I guess I could I
can defer to the attorney and or the
rest of the committee on this little
specific
okay anyone
else represent goie thank you madam
chair um just to state that if we do
pass this amendment I'm fine with it as
is without another amendment coming
forward to make that one minor change
okay other I tend to
agree okay any anyone else want to step
in representative Simon wanted to say
it'll make representative Brown's lunch
easier he doesn't have to deal with it
ah we don't want indigestion anywhere
that's for sure all right so Madam chair
I I I'll agree I I was just I was
concerned that it wasn't specific enough
but enough people with more expertise
than me and experience have said so and
I think the attorney was already had um
stated that so I'm okay with going with
it as is okay so the with with that
consensus the motion is to adopt
amendment 109h to House Bill 1385 and
the clerk can call the all
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon Sao yes
representative kill yes representative
McDonald yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt I
guess representative goalie yes
representative sht yes representative
Howard yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative man py yes and
chair yes 20
a0 all right representa Brown you have a
motion the motion has the amendment has
been
adopted representative Boyd I move uh
otpa on HB
1385 thank you is there a second
second okay do you wish to speak to your
motion okay representative gold very
well
covered all right is there any further
comments questions
concerns okay the motion is to is ought
to pass with Amendment on House Bill
1385 representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes repres Sasso no repres kill
yes represent McDonald
yes quotes yes represent Boyd yes
represent Brown yes representative groa
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
represent Smith yes represent man puy
yes and the chair yes 19 yay one
nay motion passes 19 to1 do you wish to
write on Minority
Report do you object to consent oh does
anyone else object to
consent all right thank you very much uh
we will put this on
consent
and we will break for lunch come back at
1:20
and
e
okay so
um we're going to take up 1526 and then
1521 so 1526 is the conditional
veterinarian license represent
blackis do you have a
motion I do Madam chair representative
gold has a motion
excellent what is your motion I would
like to move a to pass on House Bill
1526 all
right do you wish to speak to your
motion sure this bill enables the board
of veterinarian medicine to issue a
conditional veterinarian license for
veterinarians who are educated in other
countries in order to address the
serious shortage of veterinarians in New
Hampshire as a farmer I can tell you
I've had animals die because I can't get
a veterinarian out I've gotten um
requests from the oh I'm not going to
say their name right but the women of
the New Hampshire Farm Bureau to please
do everything in my power to assist in
in alleviating the serious serious
veterans veterinarians shortage in New
Hampshire but this bill is very very
conservative in that the veterinarian
educated in a foreign country first and
foremost has to be um have legal status
in New Hampshire as
verified by uh information that's
maintained by the US citizenship and
Immigration Services they must be
employed by a veterinarian service and
they must be under supervision of a
licensed veterinarian we also heard in
testimony that there's a a serious lag
in the processing of these
ecfvg certificates that are required in
order to complete the licensing process
in the state of New Hampshire so this is
just a temporary measure to give a
conditional license that allows them to
get through that process before and that
the board the veterinarian board has the
right to revoke these conditional
licenses at any time for any reason so
it seemed a no-brainer to me and I hope
you all will support it thank you
representative laus thank you I agree
with uh everything she said the only
thing I'll I'll point out is that when
you talk about uh uh completing the
process could take an extended period of
time it can take over a
year um and you know they've already
completed their uh you know they've had
training as a veterinarian and they've
completed all all the steps except
they're clinical and the examination
goes with it and the problem is as I
recall I think there's only a couple
places in the country with a total of
maybe 200 seats for that program and so
getting into it can take uh
over a year and then I mean not only
will this provide more Veterinary
service but it'll take these people who
are trained veterinarians operating
under supervision put them in a position
where they can at least make some money
while they're they're you know earn a
living while they're trying to uh do
their best to complete the process and
the delays are not any fault of that
so anyone other comments
questions yeah I'd like to expand on
what representative Le has said is that
this final test must be done in the US
and as he said there's only very few
slots and you so you would have to be
here waiting for a year and this bill
would allow the person to um like you
say earn a living while they're
waiting all right any repr of man py
thank you madam chair um before they get
the practicum is there a path where they
get the education and their training
accredited with there are agencies that
does accreditation for international
uh yes according to the testimony we
heard they they have already to they in
order to get to take this practical test
they have to have completed the training
and taken the
um uh essentially the licensing exam for
veterinarian and a test in English so
that they they should be able to to work
once they complete the
um the Practical the Hands-On exam which
is not always given in in other
countries follow even before they take
the exam and stuff and they come in when
I had my Masters in speech language
pathology that was not from here and my
undergrad and Masters had to be sent to
a different agency to say the curriculum
and the credits were up toart to what
was uh here that is the education so
that the veterinary schools in other
countries might have accredited one so
that that's all I'm trying I'm not
asking
there these people have completed all
steps of the
ecfvg which is something for foreign
veterinarian graduates I
imagine um and so there is a
um
um there is an established pathway that
looks at their
education it used to be there for the
doctors
ecfmg uh was the doctor's of for medical
doctors that was available and uh that
was in that was
stopped in 90s I believe well it still
seems to be working for veteran yeah so
yes good to know any other questions or
comments represent LE just wanted to
point out that there is an FN but uh
oplc said the cost will in determin it
could be absorbed in their budget so
there's no significant impact
thank you representative Shu thank you
madam chus I had concerns about this
also um however um after speaking to
members of the subcommittee um they
pointed out that the bill specifically
states that while this person is
awaiting their opportunity to get the
test they can practice but it has to be
under the supervision of a licensed uh
veterinarian or Veterinary practice so I
think that uh assures me that they will
be uh adhering to the practices that are
recognized thank you anyone else
represent Brown thank you madam chair um
following up on on your uh
statement do do we know what supervision
means because we've had this
conversation in another bill about
assistance and tethering and untethering
from their their doctor uh do we know
what supervision means and just as a
quicky educational commission for
foreign Veterinary
graduates ah thank you representative
leus you have an answer to that I I
think so um it actually providing such
person is employed by and practices the
profession under the supervision of a
duly license veterinarian so they
actually have to be employed by the
veterinarian or or the office so that're
you know they're they're tied together a
lot more closely than like the the some
of the other things we've heard about
the other thing it says um might
alleviate some concerns a conditional
license may be summarily revoked by a
majority vote of the board of Veterinary
practice so I mean they don't even have
to do the normal due process
investigation everything if they've got
a conditional license so if there are
any complaints coming in I imagine
they'd be dealt with pretty promptly
representative
gold representative Le has handled it
well it's supervised by the physician in
the office where they're working not any
stray veterinarian that wants $1,000 a
month thank you uh any other comments
questions all right the motion is ought
to pass on House Bill
1526 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakus yes representative Bailey yes
representative santon naso yes
representative kahill yes representative
McDonald yes clerk vot yes
representative V yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
manager py yes and the chair yes 2080 a
all right motion passes 20 any
objections to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
consent and Madam chair I believe you
have my report I do thank you and you
get a gold star nobody
disappointed all right house bill
1521 representative
groda thank you madam chair I'd like to
um move
Amendment
0902 H to House Bill
1521 is there a second second okay
uh before we discuss this amendment this
is a replace all so we have to decide
first if we want to support the
amendment
itself as given to us and secondly if we
do if we do support it then what do we
want to do with the content of
1521 we have a couple of choic ches the
ones that I would recommend were would
be to add some portion of
1521 into house bill
1622 which is also about administrative
rul making and so the content would be
would be
germine uh so if we have that there's
sub piece of the original 1521 we want
to include we can add it to
um 1622 if we want it to pass
immediately or we could decide to add
the concerns from
1521 to a committee study of the topic
which we can do without a bill uh the
administrating rulemaking process is
well within our scope we can just put a
committee on it and work on it
because
um the issues raised are
are are one thing the actual language of
the bill is another and we could
certainly study the issues raised
without having a bill to tie it to
representative
Schmidt thank you mam chair well I I I
really appreciate the the the little cqu
you've started off here uh I I'm very
much in support of the non- gerain
amendment uh having participated as a
couple of us were able to a couple days
ago um in the hearing on the non gerine
Amendment I'm very supportive but at the
same time I I don't want to jettison the
uh the content of of the underlying
content in other words of the bill as
filed because I think it really is an
issue uh with some of the agencies that
that are not sufficiently uh open to uh
input from the public and which
sometimes is very M and very appropriate
and needs to be out there so that the
people can see it that are not
necessarily watching the hearing or
whatever the agency is presenting or
doing at that particular time uh and
I've seen it in with regard to some
issues in the city of Rochester which is
in straford County as you know where I
uh where I am the chairman of the of the
delegation uh so I I think your your
proposal is is a very excellent one and
I hope the committee will be supportive
of retaining some and and doing
something this year with the underlying
thing I like the idea of studying it uh
because I think it deserves more than
just a
compressed treatment of it at this
particular time which was all we would
get if we were tacking it onto something
else um and we wouldn't get anything
this year so anyway that I've said
enough for the moment okay um in that
case with without objection we we will
take up the some the content of 1521
when we are discussing
1622 and decide if there is something we
want to spec amend to pass this year and
other and we will and at that point
we'll also decide if we need to create a
study committee on it okay
representative Simon thank thank you
thank you madam chair so um we're
talking about adding something to 1622
we have that on the docket for today so
are we going to delay that it's the next
one no I mean so we have to be ready to
go right now
well right so the question is do we
support this amendment and if we do we
will consider the content the original
content of
1521 while we are discussing 1622 to
because it it could be added to it
appropriately it is
Germain would we need to get an
amendment and bring that back next week
we might very well need to do that okay
thank you but we we are coming back next
week anyway so yep can be done Madam
chair representative ghoul thank you
madam chair for taking my question um
I'm trying to understand are we saying
that when we talk about 1622 we may want
to amend 1622 to include some of the pro
provisions of the original 1521 yes so
the amendment would stay the same and
could be processed but we don't want to
act on
it in
hindsight attaching this amendment which
I do support to 1521 was probably not
the best decision it should have gone
onto uh 1286 the uh combining the board
of of
which is not we don't need to worry
about follow up followup so my only
point is I really think this is
important the um recovery houses are
very near and dear to my heart and
important and this would be good
legislation for my town and so it
however you I trust your great wisdom in
how to best handle it well unfortunately
I I found out that we can't just slide
the amendment over to another bill
without another hearing but since we do
have a another bill that would be gerain
to the original 1521 I think we should
cover it
there all right so on the amendment
which representative grot do you wish to
speak to your
Amendment I'm so sorry I apologize could
you please repeat you want me to speak
to my motion yes okay or the the
amendment the amendment okay so the
amendment to 1521 replaces the entire
bill with a bill that's related to
recovery houses and one of the issues
that has happened is that because
um recovery houses are not identified in
Statute in a clear enough manner
everyone is using their local um zoning
ordinances to Define them and is causing
discrepancies throughout the the
estate um on how these um facil how
these fac facilities are managed for
example um
individual um purchased a house with a
means of having a recovery house and in
some in in some um communities if you
have two or three more people who are
not related living in the same house
then it causes a whole throw back throw
into the zoning ordinances which can
take which can delay the opening of the
recovery house and since we need these
um and the ones that we have are
operating well this was brought forward
as a way of resolving the issue so it
basically um talks about recovering
houses meaning primarily a non-transient
dwelling or dwelling unit that provides
substance-free living and um and that
the people who are living in the
recovery house are living as a single
household so that's what defines
them um so but it doesn't include a
boarding house or a rooming house so
it's very clear that it's only meant for
those people in recovery so I think that
the bill um is important enough that we
address it and that's why I'm attaching
it to 1521 and I realized that it is
caused a whole bunch of problems for
1521 but it's not something that we can
be res that can be
resolved right so thank you because I
know that
people understand that um 15201 was
trying to address something and I think
that well I'm G to stop at that right
now I'm not going to go any further we
can talk about it later okay
representative goalie you wish to speak
to your second time thank you madam
chair the only uh other comment I'll
make is that we received a letter email
to us from the Fire Marshall who is in
support of this
change yes that was your main Amendment
on the yes that's the subject of our
current debate good well that's that's
important to hear from him
yes
so yes any uh
other com
muty it's it's a question um this is
similar to group homes uh that was in
the 90s and early 2000 for people with
developmental disability living in the
community with staff or is it there no
staff it's a private residence it's a
private residence there no staff a
Recovery House are people who are sober
and living in the house with other
people okay thank you it's not a medical
or counseling or anything
facility may I Madam chair having been
there at the hearing you recall that
they did talk about a
manager uh so I don't know whe that
certainly would be considered staff but
I think there is a clear difference to
group homes and between and the recovery
houses yeah it but uh at the hearing
they did mention they might have an
employee there who would be you
know who who would also be working his
way through recovery and would do things
like make sure the the bills got paid
and every and
uh
um not so much as a as
a as a counselor as somebody that's
making sure the house operates as a
house that it's not left in the hands of
the the people who are there who are in
recovery and and who are obviously in a
fragile situation in their lives so the
ma there was a clear reference to a
manager on on
board some anyone else representative
Shu thank you madam chair um I also
attended the uh subcommittee meeting on
the non-gain amendment and I may be
stating the obvious but um these
recovery houses are a large part of
folks who are attempting to recover from
substance abuse and we obviously have a
large problem with that in this state
and I think this is an important step to
aiding those people who are willing to
try and recover thank you anyone else
represent Simon thank you madam chair um
not obviously not opposed to the content
of the amendment um my biggest concern
with adopting it is the underlying
content and I'm happy to vote for the
amendment if uh with the committee's
approval I might be allowed to work on
the language of 1521 the underlying
language to see if it will fit into 1622
and bring it back next week okay
yeah I the testimony we got was that in
many cases a person opening a recovery
house went would go to the planning
board or whomever
and they they were not aware of what
exactly was
required they didn't weren't objecting
they just said well we don't know what
we're supposed to do here so this
language is intended to make it clear to
planning boards and um zoning boards
what a recovery house is and what the
requirements
are okay anyone
else okay all right the motion is to
adopt amendment
0902 to House Bill 1521 and the clerk
can call the RO representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative santonastaso
yes representative K yes yes
representative McDonald yes C Ro yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu
representa representative Howard yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 280 n repres
son of broa you have a motion yes madame
chair I move otpa on House Bill
second goalie and gold and a tie for the
second all right we'll give it to give
this one to to Sher um all right further
discussion representative Roa
representative gold no anyone else have
a
comment representative Brown you have a
comment okay anyone else seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 1521 and the clerk will
call the role represent Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative saso yes
representative kill yes representative
McDonald yes CL votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown yes
representative GR yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Howard yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 20 a0 n all right the
motion passes 20 to zero um anyone
object to
consent all right seeing n we put this
on consent Madam chair yes may I just
indulge myself a little to say it's a
proud day to be from Warner with Ben
Frost helping to draft this language and
Fire Marshall tuni supporting it yes
thank
you all right so moving on
to
1622 which is about the rule making
process
and
I'm moving Amendment
1064 to House Bill
uh
second and I will say that this is the
result of the
subcommittee uh language this amendment
is the amendment that in the
administrative rules office brought to
the
hearing it deletes the first paragraph
of the bill which talks about
the um rul making for retention periods
because the oplc and the Secretary of
State are working on that issue offline
and I'd like to have them settle it
before we change the
law and then it simplifies the language
in uh SE
two
um that uh Madam chair did you
distribute this amendment I thought I
did oh well perhap is this amendment
over there
Jackie
okay I I
did I apologize for it not being
there it's a number
I thought several members had already
gotten it so I think several members had
already gotten it yeah Madam chair
there's another amendment which is 622
FN uh which is 2024
d368 that is the amendment that the
administrative rule
staff presented at the public hearing
this is a combination of that Amendment
Plus some other changes that were made
by the
subcommittee it's it's a historical
document at this
point yes am is make it impossible to
look at
no all right
the so this is the subcommittee
amendment
and do you want a motion or did you move
it I already made a motion did and Diane
seconded okay
good representative Shu do you wish to
uh talk to you m um I will just state
that the um subcommittee um agreed to
this unanimously uh we heard from both
um jel car staff and oplc that they were
in agreement with the amendment and so I
think uh it's proper to move forward
with it
okay all
right
so is there any discussion on this
amendment seeing none I think we should
now move into whatever content from
1521 some person some member of the
committee wants to include clude in
something to be brought forward this
year
um yes representing thank you so
um the administrative rules process is
one that has
many um
components and last year and I and I
want to
avoid making changes to the
administrative rule process when the
changes that we made last year are still
in
process I believe last year we did
address some of this public response
from agencies and those rules are coming
to Jael car
shortly so and I feel that that was a
movement of the dial and before we move
the dial again I'd like to see at least
where did this take us and can we as a
Comm
committee agree to meet and talk about
this so that we can
make a decision that is going to
be effective you know make a change
that's going to be effective that's my
concern with just you know willly just
at living and just picking stuff out and
sticking in something else we we and I
don't want to Bel labor this but we've
seen what it's done to
oplc right so I would like try to avoid
that with a committee with a with a
division with the with the
administrative group administrative
rules group and Jael car which is
complicated enough as it is so that's my
my two cents so I don't know if that's
helpful um I do believe that there is a
need
for um 1521 some component perhaps but
I'd like to really take a look at it
carefully before we add it to something
else okay uh I believe the jail car
staff has brought some examples of the
reports on on public comments to the
rules that they can uh present to the
committee so you can see what is
starting to happen because of the law we
passed last year representative lacis y
I mean I don't oppose certainly don't
oppose the idea of uh taking a look at
it care carefully and not doing in the
middle of exec session um
but I guess my only question is has
there been a a draft of the rules that
anybody's looked at and is there either
oh the rule you said CH that the they're
working on rules related to this and my
my question is um if any if nobody's
looked at them fine or they're not
available fine I was just curious if
they seem to address the issues dealt
with in 1521 or not or if
looks like there would be conflict with
what's in
1521 right now the law we passed last
year required that the agency Report
with the final propos final proposed
rule the public comment they received
and their response to it how they dealt
with
it which is and here are some samples
that you can take a look at that was
effective in O for rules starting in
October so they're just now starting to
come out
um all right I may have misspoke in my
effort to try to you know be clear what
the the the the the what we put together
went into effect in October and these
the documents that we're seeing are the
results of that which is not something
that we had before right okay so this is
new
okay and you can see there's one from
the O OPC there's one from
Dees there's a statement from uh the
Lottery
Commission that's a fairly Hefty one
that
um the the difference is that 1521 as
written as it came to us would
require
that this analysis be done
before
um um you know give gave it 90 days at
the end of the public
hearing
and that's doesn't necessarily agree
with the what what is the period for uh
for final proposals
good afternoon Mike morl director of
administrative rules within the office
of legislative
Services uh currently agencies have a
180 day limit from the time they filed
their initial Proposal with us until
they they have to file their final
proposal um one thing that the bill as
introduced does is ADD 90 days after the
agency's had its public hearing um to
put together the report that's in here
um that adds 90 days onto the whole
process which is going to require many
changes in the law but um
Madam chair would you like me to speak
further
about um
there no I just wanted to know what the
the cycle time was it's lengthy enough
as it
is representative Schmidt thank you
madam chair so I am not hostile to
progress because we we we have been on
the Jael car for some time in my case 18
years not imagine that Jael car is
perfect that the process has been handed
down from the from the Divine Throne uh
and is sub is uh susceptible to no
further Improvement and so I'm open to
the idea of anything that is going to
improve the process um but I'm also
mindful of the fact that that the gel
car the administrative rule process is
not well understood by the legislature
certainly not by the house um in in my
my 18 years of
attending ja car sessions almost without
fail I have seen State reps in front of
the Jael car committee at hearings a
handful of times it's almost always a p
particular person with a particular
problem and so and and until I got
appointed to jail car I didn't know any
more think more about it than most of my
colleagues did but I've been doing it
diligently for for about 18 years and I
know that that there's a misconception
that we've heard in this committee a
number of times that the agencies are
kind of running a muck they can do
anything they want to and they're doing
it uh I reject that because I think that
by and large the agencies are diligently
in attempting to implement the statutes
that we have enacted
which is not to say that the agencies
never overstep their Authority or
whatever and representative goalie will
remember when we had this bill a year or
so ago with regard to the Food Service
entity that was required to put a
thousand gallon tank into the into their
ground they they had been a like I think
an ice cream shop before and they
switching over
to I think crabs and and and
that type of thing uh and so for
clamshack okay and they came in and they
said you're you've got a public restroom
now which you didn't have before um
you're having people eat there and so
forth and you're putting stuff into the
ground that is harmful to the the you
know the viability of the soil to absorb
that stuff and harmful to the
environment and they required them to
put in a thousand gallon tank
and that bill came to
us and and I think a lot of us saw this
as a mistake at the very least on the
part of Dees and and also possibly an
example of
heavy-handedness um and uh and in
pursuant to that experience there was a
working group that was set up between
Dees and
HHS and I participate in that and those
most people who were very experienced
people who had been in the plumbing
business or the regulatory end of things
for years and years and they said we've
never had a discussion like this before
because they said you know the plumbing
code says that uh and we the plumbing
cone governs everything in the house and
six feet of pipe coming out of the house
and the the the the dees has a
requirement that septic tanks and so
forth and so on but there was a lot of
unclarity with regard to what happens
when the plumbing line and the thing get
close together what governs them
connecting up and transferring the
material from the house to the to the
ground and and that that working group
under all this expert input came up with
some very good
suggestions and but the point is that I
think that uh that having experienced
the turnkey landfill situation in Dober
where there were a lot of comments with
regard to older issues and other issues
um and the the dees kind of waved a hand
to some degree and said these are all
non gerain they're dismissed but when
the citizenry was myself included a
little bit later in the game got
involved and reached out and protested
about the the the way this thing was
handled and the EPA found out about
it they they said Dees you have screwed
up to put it
bluntly um and so I think this is an
opportunity this the underlying Bill
1521 is an opportunity for the for the
input of the citizenry which may be
uninformed in some instances or wrong in
other instances but that doesn't mean
that the citizens don't know anything
about anything at any time and and I
looked at the stuff that EPA uh the E
the dees subsequently put out to us put
out to the public there was a lot of
very good input from the public I don't
know whether anybody else has seen that
document but in stford County we saw it
anyway and the thing is that 1521 is an
opportunity for us and I think we should
we should take this up in and as CH as
the shair knows and some of the longer
serving members know we don't need a
bill we don't need a bill we can take up
any issue that a majority of the this
committee wants to study and I think
this is a a topic worthy of that study
but I would like to see some of the
stuff done now because if we put it all
in a an interim study nothing will
happen this year and I think some of
this stuff needs to be done this year
which means we have to consider it now
thank you very much for your
Indulgence looking at the if you want to
include something for this year the part
that would make sense to me would be to
require that public comment be posted on
the website that would be because I
believe that can be done without
interfering with the
process they particularly written
testimony should be posted there's no
reason not to and I think that would be
as you say I think that's extremely wise
proposal Madam chair all
right representative laus um just so I'm
clear you're you're proposing from the
original 1521 to take just section three
or any other part of B basically section
three okay because that is that is
something that some agencies do in part
but it uh like responding to public
comment it's something that we would
want every agency to do regularly okay
and then followup follow really comment
um to to uh representative Schmid's
comment yeah I chaired the subcommittee
on that greas strap issue is actually
between conflict between DS and the
building code review board and uh it
showed that interim study can sometimes
be useful we got them to actually fix
the problem without statute through rul
making and other things so worked out
and it shows how glamorous this job is
that I spent a number of meetings on
Grease grease
traps many years ago I chaired the fog
committee or study committee fat oil and
grease about restaurant output yellow
grease Brown grease I don't know if any
of you have ever had any contact even
smelling Brown grease but there is
hardly a more evil smell in the in in
the universe than that for
representative Schmidt representative
Simon you had a comment yes thank you
madam chair um recognize the complexity
of how this all integrates when we're
looking at the whole process um I would
just like to offer once again to the
committee um if the committee will give
me its Indulgence to take the next week
look at the language and make some
recommendations as opposed to trying to
jam it into the next 10 minutes here in
committee I'd be happy to do that work
if that's
acceptable we I think we should we need
to give you some guidance because if we
wait until next
week admittedly we won't have the final
language before then but we should have
an a consensus at least on what it
should include or what it should not
include uh because we're this time we've
got a week next week we will have
the we will not have time if if I may I
I think that the 90 days is the most
problematic part at this point and I
think um the interested parties are
interested in they're okay with having
that removed um so that we're not
slowing down the process um so I think
that would be something if we're going
to if we're going to cut that seems like
the most reasonable thing to cut at this
particular point in
time so your your suggestion is that we
incorporate section three which is the
publishing public comment because we
already have a
statutory um requirement that the
agency Report with the
final uh final rule the public comment
and their responses to it is that
correct yeah um even Part B of of one I
I would just I'd like to take a closer
look at that um and have some
conversations with a few people and just
determine if there's something that
could be done and I'm happy to keep the
chair in the loop since you know more on
this issue than I do um to not bring
something back to the committee that
isn't going to be agreeable um but I'd
like to look at that particular section
A Little Bit Closer as
well think I'm willing to work with
anybody on this because I have a lot of
respect for this committee and having
served on a long time but even this
group of people with the possible
exception of our of our subs today who
are for whom this is all brand new um
but the bottom line is there are a lot
of experienced and smart people on this
committee that have shown me that we can
we can get results when we put our minds
to it so let's let's get at this any
does anyone else have any opinion on
this representative gold thank you madam
chair I was going to volunteer to help I
think that rep Simon's suggestion makes
perfect sense and he's much um he's in a
much better position than I am to take
the charge on that but I would offer any
assistance if he needs any tracking down
comments from people or what have you
and I think the plan sounds like a solid
plan representative Bara okay I hate to
be the wet blanket in all this but I'm
going to be you know we have people who
want to be on the committee or want to
help but have no experience with the
rule making process or experience with
Jael car so I think that it's fine if
representative Simon wants to work with
someone but I think that it should
involve I hate to do this to you but I
think you should involve you and
I and maybe um doesn't hurt my feelings
I just didn't want to volunteer you for
something else I know but I'm I'm
willing to take a look at it involve
myself and involve um the chair and
involve someone from the office because
I think that that's
critical I that's the way it is I'm
sorry well if I may I I think that Mr
osterhout wasn't going to escape me and
I think he was knowing that in the no
it's not really no no this is not really
OPC this this section of the B yeah he's
waving off he wants to make sure that he
that I know I'm not going to be
bothering him but uh okay well Mr moral
and I can become friends I'm fine I'm
fine with that as well I would
absolutely volunteer to do that I think
there are hidden things here that uh not
intentionally hidden but ramifications
that most people would not
realize all
right if I
okay so let me restate what I think the
um the the action would be
representative Simon will work with
representative Schmidt with his
experience and director moral to
incorporate part three as much as
possible and possibly some other section
of House Bill
1521 to be amended in to House Bill 1622
is that agree is that what you
understand what do you accept that
charge is that agreeable to the
committee yeah yes I just
wanted re I think having two people with
director moral should be able to do
something you will be under strict
scrutiny all right is that is that
agreeable to the rest of the committee
yes yes okay any objections Speak now or
you'll get squashed not an objection but
having those people and having it
reviewed before and it's good what I
don't want is to come on next Wednesday
and have things blow up I'll drink to
that yes it will be my my every effort
will go into making sure that doesn't
happen uh representative lakus and I
will try to get whatever we've come up
with out to the committee before next
Wednesday so that you can review it
before hand that that'll be my goal yes
yes and this
is um yeah we're up against the a
deadline at this point and I don't want
to jeopardize the other stuff in 1622
which is why I was suggesting you know
part three
seems
reasonable uh the other stuff I'm going
to be very skeptical at but we will
we'll see what we can do Madam chair yes
this is a procedural question is it
possible to pass the amendment as it
stands in front of us and then do an
additional Amendment next week
sure that would kind of give that safety
net that this piece would be in
place we might as well finish it since
there's a motion on the floor so um okay
we will pass this amendment then the
whatever representative Schmidt and
Simon work out would
be to the bill as amended we can do that
agreed okay
any and let's um any other comments or
concerns all right in that case the
motion is to adopt Amendment
1064 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakus yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon nasso yes
representative kill yes representative
McDonald yes clerk quot yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative Gro yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative
goalie yes representative Shu yes
representative Howard yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative G yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes in
the chair yes 2a0 n okay so we have
adopted that
Amendment we will recess the executive
session on House Bill
1622 for Representatives Simon and
Schmidt to evaluate what parts of 1521
they want to
include
and develop an amendment that does
that and for everyone's
information House Bill
1095 has an amendment that is not yet
ready and that is also recessed to next
week um representative
groto um is going to be
taking some time to go over that
Amendment uh we will not be voting on it
today because it's we don't have the
final language but anyone who has
questions or concerns about that
amendment is more than welcome to
stay and and I think with that those who
don't have questions or concerns about
how the amendment to House Bill 1095 are
uh are off the hook for
today and they that will give them
plenty of time to write their committee
reports is there
um a reason to discuss what's going on
in 1271 in context although it's kind of
separate because pieces were taken out
if and I don't have language for that
either I'm waiting for so that's U we
will have
to I'll send that language out when I
get it I ask to have it by end of
business Thursday it was complicated so
okay I don't know if there's any reason
for me to stay now I guess is the
question okay all right thank you all
and
uh sorry we couldn't finish everything
but we're having
trouble we did
e
just so that I'm clear here does anybody
want to hear about 1095 or are you all
waiting with bathed breath until next
week I can tell Glenn's like save
me well I don't have it yet when I do I
will
yeah
e
for